[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm cabby HD here
and this is the Moto G you've probably
heard of it by now if you've watched my
videos but basically I don't tend to
talk about the price of the devices that
I'm reviewing in the video review itself
first of all prices tend to fluctuate
and something that's a bad deal one day
could be a great deal in price the next
so this is actually not one of those
devices this moto G costs starts out a
hundred and seventy nine dollars for
this smartphone off-contract which is a
ridiculously good deal and always will
be a ridiculously good deal that's super
low in terms of price for an off
contract smartphone so why is it that
cheap do you feel like there has to be
something missing something wrong with
it there's got to be a reason why the
Moto G is so cheap so that's exactly
what I've looked into and if you've
watched my Moto X review earlier this
year you probably know plenty about that
phone already so the easiest way to tell
you guys and show you why this phone is
so cheap is to compare all the things
that are different between the Moto X
and the Moto G and that's exactly what
we're gonna do so let's go ahead and get
into that first off look at the
packaging because it actually starts
there in order to get a smartphone down
to this ridiculous price that's
accessible by almost anyone you need to
cut every corner possible so the Moto G
unboxing is super simple you'll just get
the phone on top and a USB cable for
charging and data that's it no wall
adapter no headphones no SIM card
ejector tool nothing fancy just the
necessities and the same philosophy of
course goes into the phone itself you
don't get anything fancy nothing extra
over the top at all just the necessities
done very well but getting to the
outsides of these two devices there are
some physical differences between the
Moto X and Moto G starting with the way
it feels in the hand as the Moto G is
just a little bit thicker and a little
bit heavier than the Moto X the designs
of the phones are of course super
similar with the same back design and
slight curve and used to hold in the
hand and even the same awesome dimple
that I love so much from the Moto X but
the spec sheet will show that not only
is the Moto G a tiny bit thicker and a
tiny bit heavier but there's also some
internal shortcuts taken for cost
first of all Moto maker the
customization of all the colors and the
accents and built in the USA yet that's
expensive so there won't be
with moto G but there will be a sort of
a do-it-yourself moto maker with a back
that snaps off so you can actually take
the back off the Moto G and replace it
with another back end a number of
different colors but something that some
ruble back does not allow you to do is
add storage or replace the battery so
the only thing available is the slot for
the nano SIM card otherwise you are
locked into your 8 or 16 gigabytes of
storage and that battery is non
removable but speaking of that battery
this is actually one of the most
impressive parts of the phone physically
it is technically slightly smaller it's
a 2070 milliamp hour battery which is
smaller than the one in the Moto X but
in actual everyday use it's still lasted
quite a while with great standby time an
average of I'd say three hours or so of
screen-on time which is enough to last a
full day of regular use and I'm going to
go ahead and attribute that to the other
internals the operating system and
aspects so running near stock Android
4.3 jelly bean here is the quad-core
Snapdragon 400 and a full one gigabyte
of RAM now these are obviously way lower
end specs than the Moto X but in this
price bracket a quad core chip is pretty
ridiculous it's good to see it's the
quad core version of the Snapdragon 400
and performance was also very impressive
for the price I mean I was able to play
some pretty graphically intensive games
not in 1080p obviously but still without
dropping any frames and it looks a very
playable and I could also you know
browse the web and multitask and open
and close apps without a hitch now this
is definitely not as quick as the Moto X
don't get me wrong I mean you can tell
that you're working with one gig of ram
here it's not unbearable but you'll
notice that things will take a little
bit longer as if you're working with
less ram and slightly less processing
power in fact I'd say the biggest
bottleneck is actually the processing
power and not the graphics because
sometimes I had press to open an app and
the process would clearly begin opening
on the screen but then graphically you'd
have to use the processor to catch up to
where the graphics had gotten to
basically the responsiveness of the Moto
X if the most if the responsiveness of
the Moto X is a perfect 10 out of 10 the
Moto G would give me about us seven so
you're working with slightly different
specs to get you slightly different
performance but when you consider the
hue
difference in price well that's just
something you gotta love now you're also
working with a different display here on
the front so moto G has a slightly
bigger bezel all around the whole device
and it's rocking a little smaller 4.5
inch 720p display and it's an LCD
display instead of AMOLED now brightness
and viewing angles were totally not a
problem for this LCD display but colors
were definitely noticeably different
maybe a bit warmer and a little bit less
accurate but definitely not on pleasing
at all to look at just a little bit off
now because this is an IPS display and a
Snapdragon 400 not an X 8 chip you're
gonna be missing a few of the biggest
software features of the Moto X that
rely on those things active
notifications the twist to the camera
and active listening so the active
notifications from the X where you turn
over your phone and get those few pixels
that light up and indicate the time and
your most recent notifications that
stuff requires an o le D display to work
properly and not kill your battery so
you'll have to use the Moto G like a
normal phone and the x8 chip in the X
has sensors for detecting gestures and
voice dictation but the Snapdragon 400
here in the Moto G does not have that so
if you twist to try to open the camera
like on the Moto G nothing will happen
it's not listening for that and no
matter how loud you shout ok Google now
at it it's not going to respond because
it's not listening for that either
now I don't know how you feel about
these features you may really really
really want them or you may not care at
all and I think chances are if you're
picking up a sub $200 phone like this
you probably are in the second category
now there are three main things missing
with connectivity on the Moto G number
one is there's no 5 gigahertz Wi-Fi band
kind of a minor annoyance if you ask me
if it's such a cheap phone number 2 is
there's no NFC and that's a little bit
of a bigger annoyance for people and you
know an NFC chip is really really
inexpensive these days but again they're
cutting corners everywhere to get to a
price this low and number 3 there's no
LTE now the Moto G is an international
device and in a lot of the markets where
you're gonna see this phone popping up
and being really popular LTE isn't a big
deal at all so this is actually not that
surprising and NFC is sort of the
biggest omission I think that you would
expect to see in this device now the
camera on the back of the Moto G is
something that's really interesting it's
made me reconsider a lot of the way I
think about
cameras and smartphones it's a five
megapixel shooter so it's way less
resolution than the Moto X or a lot of
the other stuff we've looked at this
year but obviously the quality is not
going to be that great but if you care
about quality if you care about the
photo quality or resolution or video and
you have $179 to spend you can go out
and buy a decent $179 point-shoot camera
on Amazon and it still might not take
much better video or photo than the Moto
G so if you think about it I'm really
impressed that there is even a camera at
all in the Moto G I remember the first
Nexus 7 in order to hit that magical
$199 price point didn't have a camera at
all and we kind of dismissed that
because it's a tablet but that's one of
the emissions they made to cut down on
price so the fact that the Moto G even
has a camera at all that's even okay for
one hundred and seventy nine dollars is
incredible so basically at the end of
the day what I'm trying to say here is
the Moto G is an incredible deal for
$179 you cannot buy a better smartphone
period and availability is also really
good when this device gets Android 4.4
KitKat which if you watch my interview
with the CEO of Motorola Dennis Woodside
he promised that this device would get
it in January and I got the US version
so I'd be waiting for that in January
well this gets KitKat it's going to be
an incredible phone even more than it
already is
KitKat has lower system requirements and
runs better on lower-end devices and
this is a prime scenario where you could
take great advantage of that if you want
to say my top 5 best features of Android
4.4 KitKat I'll have that link right
below the like button but essentially
there's a lot to love about this phone
before KitKat and when it gets KitKat
it's gonna be awesome even more awesome
so when you need to think about whether
or not this is the phone for you to buy
for yourself consider the following
question is this to you the highest end
low end device or the lowest end high
end device because if you're looking for
a high end device this is not it and
this is not really as the way I see it
it's not the lowest end high end device
I see it as the highest end low end
device if that makes sense to you it is
an incredible value it gets way better
performance than any other device in
this price for reference here's another
phone that right now costs 179 dollars
it's not something you want to buy right
now but you can for the same price as
you can get a moto G I think the choice
is clear but it's up to you let me know
what your choice would be in the comment
section down below
thank you for watching this video and I
will talk to you guys in the next one
bass
[Music]
you